alles klar leute da macht man einmal so
ein quiz tja man denkt eigentlich wenn
findet die youtube liebe seines lebens
jahr was eine firma und seinem leben
begleitet auf youtube und leute ich habe
letztens auf twitter geschrieben dass
ich von der anderen youtuber den
geträumt ich habe zwar an der stelle
nicht öffentlich gemacht hat welche
youtuber nicht geträumt habe einfach mal
der traum wird wahr ich habe in dem
moment irgendwie mit ihr geschieht und
sie wollte mir zeigen
die scotts die sie macht ihren körper
verändern und ich danke wisst worauf ich
hinauswill leute auf jeden fall des
wegen der ständig öffentlich gesagt wer
das ist aber jetzt stellt sich natürlich
die frage leute welche droge passt zu
mir und es gibt künstlers lässt test.de
welche youtube passt zu dir erstellt von
der insider und wir machen das heute
wir finden endlich raus welches mit pass
und natürlich größte frage ist youtube
von der ich geträumt habe
die die zu mir passt oder nicht was
bringt von leuten zu treiben wir nicht
zu einem passen vielleicht habe ich von
der falschen person getrennt
es ist raus wir fangen mal ein zweckbau
mädels ist völlig egal wie nat king cole
kurze haare voll die farbe gewinnt seite
ist und die person richtiges jenny und
blondinen finde ich ganz süß es ist
natürlich eine dumme sache zu sagen weil
es sicher ein paar zuschauer eigentlich
relativ offenes haar farben angeht aber
ich hab einen favoriten das ist nun die
nummer zwei welche videos auf youtube
comedy block beauty lifestyle alles
rennen bullshit eigentlich vor allem
comedy ist bestimmt auch dem was viele
von euch interessiert welche youtuber
ich persönlich so schauer und ich habe
momentan einfach zwei youtube und zwar
karossen ecke dass so ein amerikanischer
kommentare schwierig zu sagen er sehr
gestört würde mich mal interessieren wer
von euch persönlich kennt wenn ihr den
kennt man die kommentare und die zweite
über die schau das hat zwei sind age 3
[Musik]
dankeschön
die beiden schaut eigentlich nur man
sonst eigentlich niemanden und das ist
comedy video sagen nächste frage nummer
drei was findest du bei einem mädchen
besonders wichtig sie sollte lustig sein
aber auch ernst bleiben können sie
sollten at aufmerksam und ein bisschen
verrückt sein
kleiderbügel ich weiß nicht leute findet
ihr die antworten witzig ich finds halt
ich mal gar nicht so witzig eigentlich
wenn er so einfach kleiderbügel
mittendrin stehen aber vielleicht findet
sie sollte heiß sein und man sollte mit
ihr viel mist machen können ok wissen
eigentlich dinge von denen ich viele
ankreuzen wollen würde
shared leute kennt er diesen ehrlichen
schmerz und ja mehr ankreuzen volt als
sie ankreuzen dürfte ich denke mir dann
meistens einfach nur so ok jetzt auch
mal ohne schwert lustig sein oder ernst
bleiben net aufmerksam dass in crazy
seien auf jeden fall
ich würde sagen so lustig sein aber auch
ernst bleiben können weil ich einfach
durch youtube eine person bin so ein
richtig gestört und humor hat leute ich
bin froh dass der großteil von euch
nicht gesehen hat was ich gestern nacht
auf twitter gepostet habe es war
wirklich hart alter ich hab's aber nach
elf minuten wieder gelöscht aber
vielleicht bringen wir folgten auch
gesehen könnte aber auch mal kommentiert
wenn du das gesehen haben ich mache ich
gern scheiße ich kenne alle ich schreie
trotzdem nicht manchmal los habe gesagt
lustig aber auch ernst ich glaube ich
auch das erste
natürlich sollte sie auch heißen klar
beschreiben ein traum ich mit einem wort
schlagfertig freundlich einhorn es ist
halt einfach nicht wird sich alter crazy
das beste war das was leute fehlen ihr
die antwort in diesem quiz witzig ich
würde crazy sagen hat ist nach doch
irgendeine person die richtig gestört
ist also meine youtube freunde müssen
einfach so richtig richtigen schaden
haben so kurz vor der psychiatrie
passiert was ist dein lieblingsessen
pizza die antwort für luca alles donuts
gemüse obst es gibt nichts was mein
lieblingsessen ist was ist mein
lieblingsessen so schien
ich würde sagen so wie ich gesagt wusste
wo es sushi in dem scheiß kurs gut ich
würde sagen das sind mal lecker war dort
in mengen kicken ein
sosehr nichts davon nichts davon was
isst du nicht so gerne ich verstehe die
frage nicht
donuts die durch schmecken was haben wir
gelacht wurde bei hd zum beispiel alles
was nicht gut schmeckt gemüse dvds ich
halt wirklich nicht so gerne muss ich an
dieser stelle sagen ich weiß nicht ob
ihr aber öfters mal ist oder auch keinen
bock drauf habt den zu essen oder das zu
essen weil es einfach nicht so lecker
ist aber ich mag es einfach überhaupt
nicht so ich weiß meine pizza
lieferservice hat nochmals auf der karte
hier margarita salami diavolo hd aber
ich bestellte einfach nicht deine
lieblingsfarbe pastell keine ahnung
schwarz schwarz und weiß sind keine
farben weiß pastell und schwarz weiß
eigentlich beides schwarz ist eigentlich
keine farbe schwarz eigentlich die
abwesenheit von farben schwarz zeigen
dass gar keine farbe da ist deswegen
nehme post l auf jeden fall wie würdest
du dich einschätzen hatte noch nie eine
freundin vor allem frauen hält die mir
ins league auf inter wunderhübsch finde
aber selten eine hohe ansprüche
[Musik]
youtube bietet zusammen weil ich weiß
auch nicht was ist aber falls ich
wirklich mag komm mit mir zusammen ich
brauche freunde genau jetzt ok körpers
bitte machen
danke schön ich glaub hat hohe ansprüche
trifft zeit echt am ehesten natürlich
gibt's mädels die interesse an einem
zeigen oder so also wie gesagt hat hohe
ansprüche
wie viel zeit er rückte pro tag im
internet beziehungsweise am handy vier
bis sechs stunden kann halt wirklich was
der 10 bis 24 stunden
ich glaube es 168 stunden weiter nächste
frage musste momentan etwas festes kommt
ganz drauf an
von mir aus vielleicht pädo blick ja ein
mensch ums leben
schnelle nummer von mir aus von mir aus
von japan kämpfen das macht liebe
youtuber landliebe youtube an
von mir aus wir können eine beziehung
empfangen wenn du willst ich habe ein
bisschen schiss vor dem ergebnis jetzt
leute aber wir klicken einfach mal auf
auswertungen
[Musik]
melina liebs melina er passt super
zusammen und dir ist der charakter am
wichtigsten erinnern wir uns an dieser
stelle kurz daran das ist hier wie
sexuell eigentlich bei spectral mag die
augsburger alles klar leute da macht man
einmal so ein christ ja man denkt
eigentlich findet die youtube seines
lebens jahr die eine was seine firma und
sein leben begleitet auf youtube und
dann steht sie einfach generell nicht
auf männer schön mein leben super toll
macht spaß auf jeden fall aber leute
danke fürs zuschauen jetzt mega spaß
gemacht dass dinge gerade zu drehen ich
hoffe euch jetzt aufgefallen
bis zum nächsten mal beantwortet gerne
die freiheitlichen video gestellt ob in
den kommentaren und
mit kurz